[Music]
we've seen an opportunity to film aerial
fight in a way that no one's ever done
before and make like annex ingress the
time everything sit just doing like a
quick test to see you know how big of a
cockpit we could use if we're doing a
video and stuff like that the cockpit
will fill up less of the screen which is
a bonus because then you can see more of
the cool footage of flying around and
stuff I think it's generally working
pretty well though I mean always plan on
crashing trying out this whole chase
thing to see how well you can chase one
drone with another and we almost crashed
whoa it looks like it seems like you're
really far away from me all right here
we go
you scream that's bad flying with
cameras trying to chase each other like
without without adding choreographed it
it's gonna be a couple crashes to be
glorious so we're gonna simulate being
in the next week dude that's okay yes
absolutely
that's it's gonna be great proof of
concept is entirely they're basically
using a custom 3d modeled
cockpit that I made and 3d printed we're
going to paint it still but basically
we're going to throw the GoPro in that
little cockpit watch the footage time it
up racing drones doing cool stunts
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
what do you think the toughest thing
will be today making a decision on which
shots coolest because they're all gonna
be pretty good these guys are really
good pilots and that's like an
understatement yeah that looked cool so
I'm gonna do that again [ __ ]
[Music]
so they've crashed Joan and now they're
going to go find it
we cross here
[Music]
I'll stand apart we'll get you start the
motors see if we can hear it you're
[ __ ] only broke broke one prop - yeah
we got the whole thing she's still
recording everything's a-okay thank you
yeah you guys got you crash we're at the
lone Pines site or something it's one of
the few places in the la vicinity that
has tall trees no underbrush
[Music]
so we're coming out of that bridge
sequence and TIE fighter just blew up
we're starting further out so we can see
the patch of trees then somehow would
then lead into going through this to
have a look above it we might be able to
find a spot to dive in yeah trees from
above over here and just dive home
straight in exactly there's another
crash boy yeah
so here's the other TIE fighter cockpit
printing right now three models are
printed with ABS plastic and ABS plastic
melts and acetone we're basically going
to use this we're going to code it on
some paper towels and hang them inside
of a bucket so the acetone will slowly
evaporate off of the paper towels so the
vapors fill in the bucket it'll slowly
melt just the ridges that you get on the
3d print and still kind of keep the
majority of the shape you might lose a
little bit of detail but you'll gain
such smoothness and shininess that is
worth it Ruth balls now we wait
I want to turn see if this works
this is after one hour
[Music]
that literally did nothing so it kind of
started working I either didn't put
nearly enough vapor or didn't leave it
nearly long enough so uh
it didn't really work it all melted
apart but it looks real smooth yeah no
this is like glassy smooth look at that
but obviously this was a little too much
because the whole support thing fell
apart
that's good gnarly looking that looks
super gross but also really nice and
glossy yeah it's still soft yeah just
bring this into the babe church and
paper bath it yeah can we just can we
just marvel at the fact that use through
3d printed bat and like we were just
like no big deal I was like I have an
idea and then you met we shot it with
drones we're 3d printing models for it
and then we're using home personal
computer software programs to do the
effects so this is the second pass of
vapor bath hang it vapor bathing it so
it's a little smoother is we can still
see some of the ridges in there but it's
better than it originally was so this is
pretty much done and ready for painting
now I've got to repeat this process for
all the other models that Sam printed
for the x-wing so these are all the
different cockpits the x-wing front
x-wing back and the TIE fighter D is
gonna paint a bunch of these that's what
I'm gonna do they're pretty rough inside
but you can definitely with like a nice
base primer you can make it look really
nice yeah to feel like songs II kind of
stuff whether it's what regardless of
the genre
Sam's almost done with the Edit and
we're running into an issue where we
need music so we are in a weird position
of trying to find someone else to maybe
do some Star Wars music but all the
covers we found so far online aren't the
best so now he finally got all these
little things pan check this out
little actually fully articulate r2d2
head the thing we're going to do next is
essentially film all these plates but we
have all these different things in place
this one is pretty much ready to go
ready to film there's a GoPro inside of
it right now
so we have three different types of
shots the idea is that I watch it a few
times I kind of figure out the motion so
then I'm going to hit record on the
GoPro and hit play
I'm going to be like that's the idea
this is all about matching orientation
so I'm going to look at that first Thai
fighter shot figure out what is the
angle of the Sun right now where we're
filming the Sun is over there so I have
to match the same angle and say that
okay this is my ground angle this is
horizontal and then from there be like
big left bank right pick up and over
I just got done filming upstairs for the
day
first off it's hard to match like a
bitwise match the actual drum shots the
other part is trying to match the Sun
angles you have to like to combine the
orientation of the footage and also keep
in mind the orientation at what you want
to tell us stuff that's shooting at the
end of the day when the sun's angles
steep obviously issues the mackerel is
causes the Sun to like flare out like
crazy
you know so it's I think it's a little
too close to the camera cause it's
really blurry but I mean if you back it
off like you'll be in focus and then
you'll just upscale it it'll be blurry
again you get upscale and it's not gonna
get blurry okay
well I think it might be worth pulling
it back look cuz this is like it's a
little fuzzy but I you're welcome to
experiment but well shoot small I gotcha
I gotcha so the goal for today was to
have all of these shots filmed and I now
realize that was an incredibly
unrealistic expectation Nico and Sam are
putting a lot of like pressure to make
sure this is all done first that we have
more time to do everything else but
honestly this is where most of the work
is gonna be so if it takes more time
that's just how it is and shooting all
this stuff last night none of it was in
focus it was still too close Sam was
adamant about trying to get it right in
camera and I discovered you can't get it
right in camera because it's too close
if you do so I'm pulling it back a
little bit so yeah the cockpit will be a
little smaller in the frame but we'll
just scale it up its 4k not a big deal
should be good to go alright to the roof
oh my god it's hot where's my phone oh
it's my pocket
Oh got the Sun we wanted TIE fighter
shot 1 take 1
I do one more take 5
I think this will be good
[Music]
all right sweet that's like some really
crispy miniature footage you know just
thing the focal plane was a big thing
so I reemployed an obj in a texture in
3dsmax make sure it's all working before
going out to element and introducing a
new variable into the situation
you guys are getting messed up mapping
on the x-wing which is probably due to
the map channel not being flipped I
wasn't here what happened but that'd be
my guess
slash know did you happen to see video
co-pilots Instagram post last night no
I'll show you a photo of what he posted
he posted this hey a nice rendering of
the next thing it's like the same X
equality textured in element 3d Oh
rigged I've been ready right now
yeah well that was good practice I guess
he hasn't released him he's just teasing
him so you need to get on your phone
right now and call him all right call
him like right now we need to get those
models ASAP because they look really
good respond to my mom real quick mother
for the score of this piece we're
working with a guy named Blake Robinson
he is from Australia you can check out
his YouTube channel to black guests like
us DLA K us for this we're basically
writing an original track that uses a
lot of Star Wars motifs but we're going
to be avoiding the traditional epic
themes in place of that what we're doing
is we're going to take other surahs
themes that are usually not played in
action sequences John Williams meets on
simmer that's the goal anyways today I
do respond yet
I want these models I'll pay for them
why'd you say gonna tell you
you're not
reshooting this stuff is actually here
very common at Sam as I mentioned
basically the whole intro kind of had
like this existential crisis like what
is this video we have some really cool
drone shots and it's like alright let's
embrace that make everything real and be
like drone star wars but then we did the
whole intro but nothing really like
spoke that it was drones
we went back refilling those shots with
the props on we're gonna have him
actually start spinning because once
they start spinning you can't really see
him
andrew is such a cool guy that I texted
him I'm like hey we're making a Star
Wars drone video and we're using element
3d any chance you'd want to share us
that pact with us early and he was like
okay so if you check your email right
now and you'll have a direct download
link to all the models my yeah okay Oh
yeah do bb8 as well lightsaber dude see
a TIE fighter
see you next wing see an r2d2 oh man
just want a video copilot is the best
[Music]
basically the last couple days we've
been dropping in element 3d models of
x-wings and TIE fighters into all of the
shots and what's great about this is
because we actually had a real drone
flying through the scene basically we're
just point tracking the drones and so
we're overlaying the model on top of
that we're just really the only thing
we're changes we're animating the
orientation of the models but the
position of where it is on-screen is all
real since it is Sunday morning the
video goes up tomorrow we only have
basically the rest of the today to
finish off the shots which I am
currently in the process of finishing
and then color grading finished sound
design of waiting for music and then
doing the final render a little jacked
up on caffeine right now the audio
quality of two moments right now
noticing is a little lackluster it's the
engine sound used for the drone taking
off for the first time when the props
start spinning and then also when the
x-wing punches it when it goes into the
sky I also wanted to keep it kind of
money because if we're inside the other
copy yeah what you could try and do is
maybe a couple sounds that would sound
similar distant explosion like a muffled
look like just like that it's more of a
pump than it is like a roar
well do something like in that range but
just just that maybe combining with
something just a little light something
on top still doing really well they're
all looking great super excited I go to
drop all the shots into the timeline and
they all look bad
basically I've been doing all this setup
on this computer and then all the
rendering on this computer so I'd set up
the shot get all the shots ready but for
whatever reason opening the exact same
project file on this computer it's as if
the lights aren't even there this one
has all the nice highlights on the top
it actually looks like it's being
directionally lit by the Sun here it's
flat it looks like it's in a shadow
that's gonna take hours this is Sunday
this is Jason is final music or just
another pop music do you think he'll
have to send us another one wrong make
me nervous
yeah me too info that's why we download
it listen to it
oh it's so good oh well I didn't finish
listening to her you gotta put it on
some big speakers okay okay
no pressure Chris right
this isn't dumped her own YouTube video
the music is so much better it's so
important so can we call that like
finally sigdi enemy no time
it's up that it's so much better than I
ever could've imagined okay so I just
reinstalled the driver for the graphics
card and booted up after-effects and
still it's flat however that's because
it's a cached frame I'm going to purge
the cache and hopefully this works
all right I wanna truth this is without
ray-tracing boom with ray tracing it
works good to go now I just got to
re-render 30 shots it's gonna take hours
all right so it's 5:10 Sunday and we are
gonna check our kind of final review
here finally get to watch all the shots
in one place at one time so hopefully
it's cool I don't have a lot of flats on
it but I definitely have some I think
right now the animation of the cockpits
and the rear cams is a little overboard
right now on the rear cam yeah yeah like
I've are teaching specifically the r2d2
ones but I think in general I think the
end of the cockpit animation skinny
carried away if we're redoing every one
of these shots it's not every single one
we finally have seen all the shots in
context what seemed really cool working
on a shot in the context of the entire
video and just how everything is like
doesn't work but really happy with
everything right now I mean this thing
is like wicking bomb at this point we're
just kind of doing polished passes
everything's in real good spot you have
a lot of renders out these three over
there happening there's four over here
happening and that is yeah we'll be
we'll be on here at this is the last
shot in the video rendering
it's good it's about 10:20 10:25 p.m. I
go here since 7:00 this hour boy yeah so
we're all gonna take some time off this
week does a patreon supporter video all
the work and energy that's gone into it
is all possible because of that three it
that being said I don't want to know
Elsa I wanted me oh I can't I want to do
shout out three of our patreon
supporters in particular one we got
Brian from mayhem parts yeah check out
his youtube channel we also have so so
is Hiro he's an awesome cool cat check
out his youtube channel as well and john
Welch and you can check out his channel
at thunder bunch so these three guys
helped us out big time and we're nearly
down to the video so that's how the
magics made I want to go see Game of
Thrones though yo no Game of Thrones
until the video is done no that's it oh
crap in longer oh goodness be touched
it's like you're really gonna get broke
the lens no it's seriously what oh yeah
I totally did
are you zoom punch things too hard yeah
huge broke the lens that is the end of
this lens is that what you're telling me
yeah is the end of the video
meanwhile in the behind the scenes of
the behind the scenes the scenes are
behind and beam if I can catch